la nouvelle ministre allemand des
affaires étrangères était à moscou ce
mardi au programme une première
rencontre avec son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov crise ukrainienne
sécurité en europe gazoduc north stream
2 dans un contexte tendu il s'agissait
de rétablir la voie diplomatique pour
anna lena berlocq au lendemain de son
séjour à kiev et parallèlement le
secrétaire général de l'otan a appelé la
russie et les alliés de l'otan à de
nouvelles discussions les précisions de
notre correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
presque trois heures de pourparlers les
chefs de la diplomatie russe et
allemande se sont plongés dans un nombre
de dossiers qui fâchent lors de leur
premier tête à tête à moscou il était
surtout question de la sécurité en
europe et la menace présumée d'une
escalade militaire russe en ukraine
sergueï lavrov a déclaré que la russie
allait être surtout guidé dans sa
stratégie par des démarches concrètes de
ses partenaires occidentaux je vous
propose d'écouter nous ne demandons
qu'une seule chose c'est que ce qui a
été convenu soient respectées je le
répète encore une fois il s'agit des
accords de minsk y sont sabotées par les
le régime de kiev nous ne menaçons
personne mais nous entendons des menaces
à notre adresse et cela
j'espère que ce ne sont que des émotions
nous allons juger sur la base de mesures
concrètes et en fonction des mesures qui
sont prises
par nos partenaires nous définirons
notre mode d'action le dossier nord
stream ii était également au coeur des
discussions achevées en septembre 2021
le gazoduc a été victime d'une panoplie
de sanctions le régulateur allemand
peine encore à délivrer la certification
qui permettrait enfin aux plaines de
fonctionner la chef de la diplomatie
allemande encore une fois promis des
conséquences s'il aussi concrétiser
c'est rouge est supposé en ukraine
écoutez
oui d'un autre accord de coalition du
nouveau gouvernement nous avons souligné
que les projets d'infrastructures dont
justement tous les projets
d'infrastructures énergétiques et y
compris le nord stream 2 à présent à la
procédure a été suspendue et à
différents niveaux notre gouvernement
insiste que si l'énergie est utilisée
comme une arme ce sera des cons ça aura
des conséquences
appropriées y compris dans le domaine de
ce gazoduc les deux ministres ont
souligné qu'il existait de nombreux
sujets de désaccord entre les deux pays
cependant pour anna lena meyer book il
est nécessaire de poursuivre le dialogue
et pour sergueï lavrov l' échange de
points de vue qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui
à moscou a montré qu'il était possible
d'avancer et surmonter les différends
entre les deux pays